hey welcome uh
we're here on the on the 12th of
October uh with the the committee on
committees
uh looking to uh continue to reduce a
number of committees and commissions
that
uh legislature is dealing with
specifically today we wanted to uh
review the first first up was to review
the
trifold uh pamphlet that that uh Miz
Fitzgerald passed out last time we were
here and so we'll like to go around the
whole room a little bit at a time as to
what your thoughts were or any
suggestions that you have to um change
some of the emphasis or some of the
words or uh reemphasize what's
here U
so you want to
start and I get my my
one be better in the template
appro I was wondering if in the
where disc did you get backgr
information do you have legisla I think
there's a way
question do you think it's like a banner
of some sort on
here
question yeah like
yeah under the where to begin it says
the problem you're trying to solve is
you so somewhere right in there yeah to
begin Oney the imag
you are you trying to solve what
information do you not have um have you
talked to
OS have you gotten legislative history I
mean it's the same information you guys
have in here I'm just wondering if
freezing its questions would um make
people engage a little more I think
sometimes it's easy to gloss over when
you're reading information and not
really think about the step you have to
take to satisfy it so basically
represent R to change it all to
questions as opposed to bullets yeah I
think that's Bas that's and others may
not agree that just was my initial
thought looking at it and I don't know
that that would change anything with the
study purpose or or
um yeah and think specifically about the
where to begin section
um but you know other have thoughts
about whether there's ways that could be
incorporated to other sections as
well what do you
think uh overall I really like it I
think I I like representative
rbos you know the questions as prompts
at least under number one clarify the
need um and I actually don't think that
it by starting those first two as
questions I think the rest of it can
flow just fine the way it's written
um I think it's great I mean it is very
text heavy right I
think did a really great job adding some
photos to make it engaging something
that people are actually gonna take the
time to flip through um and it brings it
to life a little bit obviously um I
think and this is maybe a question for
the larger group if we feel like it's
too text Heavy does it make sense to put
a URL or a QR code or something like
that where you can get more information
on it and I don't I don't have strong
feelings on it I I would take this and
feel like I've got what I need it's
tough I like if you put a code then it's
another step people to take text and I
don't know if people do it but I I do
understand we're trying to get a lot in
here and it's it's dense
um which almost want like if if we do
have the template online at some point
if a link to the template is worthwhile
maybe because that's something people
need to fill out um but I don't know
what would be best thoughts about lack
how to cut down on density in just for
review there is a template right the uh
template is just at a starting point
right now we haven't finished it and
that's going to take a little bit of
time as we're in our busy period right
now um but I I like your idea of a URL
or you know a QR code because there is
you know additional information that we
already have and that we will have in
the future so I think that would be
great if we just have one point to point
everybody to I we to the point of the
questions I think when we first did this
we had them as questions that where to
begin but it's you know it is a lot of
information to fit in a trifold and we
had to change it I mean not that we
can't make it a question again it just
does change the formatting in the in the
temp tell me why you decided not to do
that because maybe there are reasons I'm
not thinking no that was the reason
because of the yeah the formatting so we
we could consider that again and you
know work with it some more this of
course it's just a draft but um I I
again I also like really like that idea
of a URL or a or a code here so we can
point to where all of our information is
and where the template will eventually
be great thank you just know that me
sharing these ideas is uh it's not
because I think this is not great
because it's excellent It's because I
feel like I'm really put on the spot
that I
need we to improve it somehow feel like
the perfect the of the good here a
little bit I mean this is the good
pamphlet
but John what do you you got any
thoughts um I read it over quite a few
times and the more I read it the better
I liked it and my
only thought with it is when we do the
training we go over this and the
training for the newbies is
mandatory this this isn't you know oh I
I know how to do this stuff no we got
people who have been here two and three
turns don't know how to do this right
and even even the Reps that do know how
to do it I've done this for you know
four terms and I'm going yeah this is
pretty cool and it gives me another
Insight every time I read it there was
more information that I got out of it so
I like it and I know it's
preliminary I like it and I think the
training to the newbies on how to do
this should be virtually
mandatory because it doesn't matter
whether you've been here 6 eight years
like I have or this is your first or
second
day if you want to do it right do it
right we are planning on having training
in the new member orientation as well as
in chairs and vice chairs training at
the beginning of a term and then we'll
have the continuing ed I don't know if
we can make it mandatory but certainly
we're trying to encourage participation
as much as possible and if you can f if
you can folks if you folks can help help
us to encourage participation that would
be wonderful but yeah during part of the
training we we will hand these out even
if just in a draft form I think it would
be helpful to have these in a draft form
initially as we work through things and
find little improvements before we spend
money and and print them professionally
that's what the mail boxes are for thank
you let me piig you back some of comment
you said for the training
part what if just throw this out as a
thought what if we deput deputize and
use that word uh the folks on this
committee to go out to the various
policy
committees uh and give a you know a five
or 10
minute uh dump as to you know what this
is all about why it's important how do
you do this uh going through the
pamphlet I don't know what do you what
do you guys think about that would that
be effective do you
think
I'm not sure I think we can leave that
up to you I will just say that I believe
that all the chairs and vice chairs have
you know received a similar message as
to what you folks are doing and the
importance of of these I I don't know if
they're pushing that down to all of
their committee members or members that
aren't on committees I'm not sure how
they're getting the message but if you
think that would be
valuable and the other item I want to
mention that when we've had these in the
past um 2019
2015 and I don't know how many years
back this has always been the best
attended of all of our continuing ed
programs and the room was always packed
with at least 150 packed into the seats
and the Overflow out into the um hallway
so I think that we'll be able to Dum up
plus we're also we're going to think of
other enticements to make sure that
people are here so we'll make an effort
and also as Deborah mentioned
the chairs and vice chairs meetings we
will talk it up and we'll ask all the
chairs and vice chairs to ask their
membership to to
attend yeah and say you know and we can
encourage our ranking and Deputy ranking
members to do the same and uh if anybody
has a creative idea given that our
caucuses are pretty uh pretty evenly
split in the house chamber if we want to
do some sort of a friendly competition
around attendance you know pizza party
something like that you know good idea
happy to entertain them yeah we can we
can lean on the the speaker to buy pizza
that's right and and I I think I think
at the training that we should be part
of the
training because we're the ones who are
basically blessing this thing and
understand in depth what happens if you
don't follow the rules and we can speak
to that along with the training I think
we we could everybody can add their two
cents in or have a little little piece
of what we're doing well certainly
discuss that with the speaker he has
provided recommendations of of members
and staff who
will participate in the presentations
during the training it's a short amount
of time to cram in a lot of information
too but um we we'll bring that back to
the speaker for sure thank
you yeah um I just have a little bit of
feedback that's going to be encouraging
for you um this past week a season
legislator reached out to me and said
hey I know you're working on a format do
you have it yet do you have it yet cuz I
have you know a bill I'd like to put in
and I said you know we're still working
on it but I think that that speaks to
the work we're doing people know about
it and they're looking to do it the
right way so I I think this is great and
it's going to be helpful and I think
that legislators are are looking for
guidance So yeah thank you by the way if
you if you're you're hearing in the
background some beeping noise you're
wondering what what that is that's
that's me beeping I I I'm a diabetic and
I have a device that I wear that's
beeping telling me to find a piece of
candy I'm I'm okay I just I just want
you to not be afraid that we're we're
about to have a fire alarm or
something thank you thanks now that we
know we're gonna be
operating right have some thoughts or
comments
yeah um no I I was not nodding along
along with representative Sheen because
I've had the same experience over the
last weeks during filing period of folks
asking really specific questions so I
think that's a really good sign um but
no I I love the flyer and my only
feedback was and I don't know if you
have room for this but um just to spell
out what HCS is the first time it comes
on that first column of where to begin
so I it's it's on the I think it's on
another panel like health committee
services but here on this panel of where
to begin it says OS will work with HCS
and I'm just thinking I was actually
here for kind of a long time before I
knew what HCS stood
for so I'm thinking for our newer folks
if if you can fit fit house committee
Services equals HCS down there I think
that would be a little helpful just a
minor thing thank you so you want it
bulleted there in both places yeah okay
all right and again we were doing that
for the I know I was just thinking
people are going to open it up here okay
and see this probably before they see
that back panel yep so that's that's
just yeah and I don't know if
that anyway good Fe I also think it's
fine if it doesn't happen just to be
clear we want to be as clear as possible
so we can do that change thank you thank
you repetition is good
right what they say people get it after
about three or four times yeah Jim what
do you
get I really don't have anything to add
I apologize for being late uh today um
yeah I I thought that the the I'm I'm
assuming that this has not changed since
the last time we saw it yet and so I
looked over I thought it was a a very
nice summary so um I think it looks good
one of the thoughts that I had
was
um I'm just thinking if I was a
freshman and try to walk myself through
it it would be nice to be able to have
something like this that
was would also lend itself to a
fill-in-the blank type of pamphlet so I
would take this around with me I'd go to
OS I'd go to
to uh HCS to HCS and I I'd go to my my
local chairman and I'd be making notes
or writing things down that I needed to
do but there's no space put that I know
I know
uh having a lot of space in a trifold is
not doesn't they don't really work
together so I don't know if it if it
means should it should it
be for folds instead of three should to
be two sheets that staple together I I'm
just thinking of a way to expand a space
for a a young legislator to start making
notes of who he who he or she spoke with
or or what's next for them to do or who
to go see
next I'm thinking as a freshman I'm
going to go talk
to the minority leader and and he's
going to tell me make sure you speak
with chairman Smith on this one and make
sure you go see well how do I keep it'
be nice if I had some a spot to make
notes of what he told me or or what I
have to go do and so so the so it's
really a geography issue geography of
where you would where we could find the
space to do that you don't want to make
the printing so small that you need a
magnifying glasses to see it but just
feedback to think about is is there a
way to do that is like I said is it a
second sheet is it a quad fold instead
of a trifold
or so that's that's my feedback yeah Jim
um one way to achieve that is with a QR
code um that points to a website um it
takes up some real estate on the thing
but you could potentially put it on the
front but it's a kind of for more
information and it gives people a quick
way to get there I second that I think
it's a great idea that you would scan
what right it's it's it's one of those
um Square codes that looks like a bunch
of sort black and white dots and it just
you scan it with your phone it takes you
to a web page so um I mean you you could
just as well put a URL on here but
people MH usually aren't going to type
it but but if you you have a QR code
people just you know for our new our new
younger legislators that uh would have
to now come back teach us how to use the
QR
code it'll be I think it's a great
learning opportunity for everybody teach
them how to establish study committees
and commissions they teach us they teach
us about QR
codes if I may Mr chairman yes first of
all leader wilham suggested that as well
and that I think that's a great idea
adding a QR code for more information
sorry I keep turning away and then I
lose the mic uh the other on on your
idea about making notes I think it might
be helpful when we have that study
template ready to go because that will
pretty much be in a fill theblank you
know fill theblank format as far as the
things that we need in a in an LSR for
this type of you know for this type of
LSR for a committee or commission so I
know we don't have that yet and it'll be
a little bit before we have it but that
may be an area where you can make notes
on because that's where you'll be
filling in name of the commission and
you know the the start date end date the
appoes that are needed and and stuff
like that I'm I'm thinking
uh what comes to mind when I think about
that process is OS is that is that a a
spot when when they you know we're
directing them to go to
OSS is that where they get that
information I with a with the QR code
they can bring it up themselves well
when they go to os does s hand them a
sheet and say this is what here's
a you know a 90% blank sheet with
fill-in the blank stuff is that where
they get it perhaps we'll have to
confirm the the details on the process
for the template after we have the
template I mean I think that's a
reasonable expectation but certainly
with the QR code it can bring you right
to the template as well
yep anybody else have any additional
thoughts about about the
trifold we should do it great great job
by the way it's it I think uh we 98% of
the way there so any suggestions you're
getting from us are just to enhance
what's already there not to really
change
much
um okay uh John you wanted we wanted the
floor okay thank you uh our past list of
uh recommend recommended committees and
commissions which we want to uh put in
the
can uh I sent out on 1011 a memo to uh
four of the people that are on different
uh RSA committees I I picked out four
committees out of the stack of however
many there are and uh I took
49-1 uh 28
B1 25 j11 and 404
J1 and I sent this memo out to uh the
people that were listed on the committee
list and it says good evening
representative shirtliff Wier Harrington
and hunt and I
copied uh I sent it to them I copied Deb
uh
an Vanessa the chair Sherm and the
speaker good evening Representatives you
are all members of a commission which is
being reviewed for removal from the rsas
due to some particular reason as the
vice chair of the committee on
commissions I am tasked to investigate
removing slash repealing commissions no
longer
required the following is a list of
commissions with RSA which are being
recommended for removal repeal this is
just my piece of the list you may or
will be contacted by other members of
the committee Visa Vis other commissions
or rsas being considered for removal
please let me know ASAP whether you as a
House member on the commission concur or
not and like I said I selected four of
them uh I got this was two weeks ago and
I got re I got uh answers back from all
four of the members uh the first one was
uh from representative schliff and uh I
recommended uh my qu my question to him
was question can this maintenance be
done in conjunction with virtually all
other New Hampshire State memorials in
conquer uh in as much as it is a state
uh sculpture on State Property should
not the state automatically be
responsible for maintaining
it uh which is a logical question and I
got some some uh an answer from the
representative and I would like to
discuss this uh in a few moments uh my
second
was
uh 28 B1 County State finance committee
which I sent to representative
Wier and my response from that reset
representative wer was basically it's
okay to kill it so there's one hard
kill uh 125 j11 air pollution advisory
committee and I sent that to
representative
Harrington and uh the commissioner and
representative Harrington said yes this
this can easily be
killed uh my last room was 404 J1
Commission on status of health coverage
markets for individual and small
employees in as much as I'm on Commerce
Committee I hear this all the time and
my uh rep representative H said yes I
already have an LSR in place and if you
want to pull that uh we can combine this
with the uh Bill sitting
in uh V uh representative shien's uh
committee that we're going to pile all
these guys on and chop them off in one
lump sum now what I would like my
comrades here to do I see one two
three four five six there are six
committees and representative Shen has
already taken 356 B70 and said she'll
take care of that one now I would like
everybody else to pick one or two that
they would be willing to follow up with
uh the representative
responsible uh for that uh for that
RSA so Mr
chair tell us tell us what's okay U the
the I have a problem the first one HB
258 chapter 7
2711 is not there's no current
appointments so I would automatically
recommend that this one be killed I'll
take that one you'll take that one you
got it okay good uh and see if you
wanted to check and see if there's
anybody that's interested in that thing
you know e you know from from any
view because that that one might take a
little extra research okay before you go
are you getting enough of
this okay uh representative Rambo I used
the list that we had yes okay oh the
okay RSA
491 was representative
shff and rep representative Wilds 28 B1
right
and yes
perfect and representative Sheen is 356
B70 she's she's took that
one okay so we're good may I ask a
couple questions yeah go ahead sh the
the first question is on the wi and
Memorial will speaker shlif be coming in
to speak about that I I invited him and
uh his take on that was
well he really didn't want to see it
because I don't I don't know maybe a
personal reason but because it's a state
Memorial on State Property I'm
recommending that the state take over it
because they they have it anyway and
what I what I what I believe his
commission is is being is a
watchdog and do we need another Watchdog
commission just for every
state
piece of material we have one State
Property what's his thought on it what's
shir's thought on that he well okay I
will I have the response
here uh hi John yes it's my
understanding that maintenance on the
wet Memorial can be done in conjunction
with other state memorials in conquer
now let me give you some background of
why the three-person wiing committee was
formed when I introduced the legislation
to have the wet Memorial placed on State
Property the grounds of the New
Hampshire State Library I also include
the provisions for a three member wi
committee that's a committee not a
commission committee automatically ends
at the end of the
banum but it is a commission anyway uh
the original
one sometimes the terms are used
interchangeably this way was drafted but
anyway I know it's a commission anyway
because it's an RSA uh the W the
original Wier fundraising committee was
concerned that the state was always not
the best custodian of historic
properties and memorials for example the
conditions of the Robert Frost Farm in
Dairy the Daniel Webster Farm in
Salisbury Etc so similar to the state
law enforcement memorial legislation I
included the provision allowing for the
three person wiing commission currently
the commission is made up of myself Paul
Smith and Carrie Johnson from the New
Hampshire State Historical resources
because of the relative newness of the
wet Memorial the committee hasn't had to
provide any additional maintenance in
the future if we find that additional
maintenance work is needed for the wiet
memorial that the state is unable to
perform the whing committee will be able
to fill that
need that sounds like he's not in favor
of he's he's really not in favor of
getting rid of it but it is a state
Memorial on state Grant grounds and the
responsibility to maintain State
memorials on state grounds is the state
of New
Hampshire why
would this one Memorial have an
oversight Committee of three
people it sounds like we need to have
Steve come in and talk to us I I'm of
the belief yeah like I said there's
enough
opportunity that I don't I don't think
we need to wrestle over any of these no
I'm saying that that we need to discuss
but the other ones
uh um I got uh R 125 j11 Bob Scott the
dees commissioner says that's not needed
when the commissioner said it's not
needed it's not
needed final report okay 404 J1 the
final reports due December 2024 and John
Hunt already has this on LSR to kill it
so we can asked John to pull it and put
it on the on with us on the bill that
we're
amending
um uh representative wer his
comments like I said I have copies of
all these
memos just trying to find it in that
mess representative Wier says uh they
didn't they had meetings they never
really got anything out of it so he says
yeah kill
it and uh
okay anybody
want uh 4 c37 Commission on demographic
Trends last report was in
2018 Representatives Griffin Murray
pitri and
Wier
I don't see a lot of hands going
up I already did my four I'm not doing
any
more which
one oh thank
you representative
Simpson
uh you got
representative well Mary Griffin's not
in the house anymore it could be Barbara
Griffin also oh Barbara Griffin also the
house okay
well yeah 4
c37 which is archived I can tell you
that the the the the the issue of
democratic demographic Trends came up in
Carol Maguire's Committee in the last
session
and the decision was made um not to
invoke a new committee or or amend uh a
new opportunity because uh UNH was was
suppli was supplying that data free of
charge
without any oversight needed and the uh
everybody on the committee and both
sides of the aisle thought that what UNH
was supplying was more than adequate and
we didn't we didn't need a another
special committee or commission to
oversee
that so that that's a source for I would
I would suggest just touching base with
Carol
Maguire and
and okay yeah and perhaps her the
ranking member make sure you
got a uniform thought on that sure thank
you definitely it sounds like
maybe reaching out to the Senate might
also
be yeah that maybe the house was more
willing to do is that what I'm reading
am I reading that correctly that maybe
the house was more willing to get rid of
it but we need both bodies to agree so I
I
think to repeal it we don't need both
bodies uh but it would make it cleaner
if we had both bodies but I think I
think on our own we can we can end a
committee or or a commission without
without the Senate they they they can
also do the same thing without
us I think that I had I don't know I
don't know if that's true I think I
think in order to repeal a committee or
commission which is established by both
Chambers we need to we need to pass
legislation through both Chambers and
then have it signed by the Govern you
have any thoughts on that
yeah that's that's laws we it's a law
and we can repeal it both both houses
have to repeal
it all right uh anybody want yes that
makes sense and I did just forward you
an email which has information on the
house members and the senate members as
well I did have one more question I hate
to go back back again but I just want to
make sure I'm clear the the Harrington
and representative hunt bills okay hunt
and Harrington have lsrs in yeah all all
I wanted to say is I did let them know
that the speaker prefers that they pull
their lsrs and include it on the retain
bill sp84 um I I mentioned that but I'm
just a staff person will a legislator be
following up with them to make sure and
yeah that's that's exactly what I got
from both of them they'd be willing to
pull them if oh perfect we're g to put
them on the okay so you already reached
out to them to let them know about sb84
and and that's yeah because that's
that's what I said removing appealing
and
John I got to figure out which one's
from
which that's Ken
Wier oh that's
Harrington and
that's you have John Hunt okay Vanessa
you have a thought of when that is gonna
legislation's going to come before the
the house
84 well we we still have it retained we
haven't um done anything with it cuz
we're waiting um so it'll come up as a
retained uh bill for action with with an
amendment with an amendment yes I see
okay okay but you have a I'm sorry you
have a a a date of so that we're going
to execute um no because we're waiting
to see what we're going to do here the
speaker asked him not to exec okay it
doesn't need a rules change or anything
it's just just dispositioning the retain
bill it's my understanding that we would
after November
17th exception but yeah but gre's
working with the speaker right if it's a
retained bill you will have to report it
out by November 17th as amended but I
think you have enough time it's a month
away yeah well we only got six more to
play
with all right uh from John Hunt I do
have an LSR to repeal 404 one if you
have another bill that will repeal it
I'm okay with passing it okay uh from uh
representative Harrington John I was on
the air pollution advisory committee for
at least a year before I even knew it it
has not met met since and I have been on
it I checked with the commissioner of
Dees Bob Scott and he said it was no
longer needed that's why I submitted an
LSR to eliminate it can that will that
be added to the yeah these are ones
we're adding to uh so that all comes out
in November in November that's all my my
red list and representative Harrington
is okay with pulling that LSR yep he
said that's why I submitted an LSR to
eliminate it all I got says hey Mike
pull it we're going to we're going to
add it to the list now procedurally stay
with John when they pull an LSR like
that does it have to make its way
through all the all the the co-sponsors
as well pull the sponsor just pulls
it yeah the sponsor can just pull
it until it gets gets to the speaker you
can pull though and
LSR I've been around this thing a few
times
okay anybody on uh
I4 advisory committee on state
procurement what is it again 20 it's on
it's right here it's on your list that
you got in your book 21 i4d advisory
committee on state procurement the house
representative AAR Emerich and Shu and
Senator Carson the last comcom discussed
converting to an ad hoc but needed
further discussion the members were
reduced in 2022 two years
ago okay representative
rbo you can work with AB as
well it it wasn't a a bear Emer and
shuet you got you got the list right
yeah okay good so you okay uh the next
page is already taken care of I did 28
B1 125 j11 representative sheens got 356
B70 404 J1 is done there's two
more uh 485 F6 long-term seat Coast
Commission on drinking water
uh representative donelly McGuff Muse
Perez and
Edgar and the es is the agency Senator
Al Schiller and Perkins quoka and notes
it is a struggle to get members who are
willing to serve and remain for the
duration of their term feedback has been
that it is not productive one rep
mentioned that it is a duplication of
Dees efforts which it may be if you
contact the dees
commissioner committee could discuss
with house members who are currently
serving as a starting
point do I have a
volunteer that wants to pick that one
up you want to grab this
one basically they me mentioned already
that they don't
want and now who's who's the leader ERS
ship that's saying they don't want it um
feedback has has been that it is not
productive
so uh get a hold of mcgu or or one of
the senators or donelly somebody on the
list and say hey what's your what's your
feeling from your committee and they can
and say I need I need you to get back to
me within two weeks so by the next
meeting we'll have this whole
thing figure out what we want to do with
it and then we can move on and put
together the
paperwork from
uh down here I put the amendment
in
to kill it the the one word that that's
per peing my interest is it's a duplic
duplication Dees effort yeah get a hold
of Dees commissioner going all the way
back though to the to the uh committee
the citation that um it's a commission
on drinking water drinking water is such
a Hot Topic right now in the state I I
don't know if it's a duplication or
something else if we could get support
widespread support to kill it U I'm just
thinking out loud it's got to be on a
Christmas tree
bill got any
thoughts I know with you know with the p
and all that stuff that's going on I
will just note that we have a Pas
commission that is very popular we have
several reps who always want to be on it
every year um and there's a struggle to
pick from the long list of people
interested that is a separate commission
than this one this one it is hard to get
members interested in serving and to
remain on let me wrestle with this one
and see what I can come up with thank
you representative
Dolan it's all
yours spell my name right there d right
not d right I want a dollar dollar right
all right now the last one
is inter 651 E2 interbranch criminal and
Juvenile Justice Council representative
long rhs and
Roy is he a senator
now
pentos is she in house no she's not
house any
longer and Senator Whitley active before
Co 19 Council work resuming an acting
executive director of the New Hampshire
judicial Council in process of
scheduling meeting and this was as of
September
2023 actually he the acting director has
um contacted us because he wanted to
meet in the LOB and as you know we don't
have outside groups meeting in the L so
he was looking for an alternative place
for them to meet and I haven't been in
contact with him since he may have found
a place to meet and they were very
active meeting on a regular basis here
um so I'll find I will get the name of
the acting executive director for
someone to um contact to find out where
they may have been meeting right right
up until now and they as we've mentioned
before some of these groups that meet do
not contact our our office or the
clerk's office so we have no way of
knowing that they are meeting and it
sometimes do not end up in the house
calendar but I will get that
name Roy is he a target
of trying to uh kill this I don't
know Terry I can reach out to them and
ask you want talk to want take this one
yeah I'll take that one okay we I'll get
that name for you you're welcome yeah
and I think doesn't mean we have to kill
it but once we had know okay when did
they have a last meeting do we have
published minutes uh when's our next
scheduled meeting it might kind of get
them off the dime too saying oh yeah we
we want to keep this going it's active
it's it's important and you know maybe
just a little a nudge well and if we
can't get clear answers we can invite
yeah we can invite them in and have them
tell us um
sometimes when people put on the spot a
little bit they get a little a little
more
focused but if it was active that and
then something
happened yeah maybe we just a little
nudge to get them going again instead of
you know killing it you'll get them
active you start publishing minutes
again right okay uh this being done
that's my piece of the pie today okay
thank you all thank you for doing that
was great
Mr Vice chair I was just going to ask
would you mind emailing either just me
or if others are interested I'd love to
see the email or one of the emails you
sent to those out I will send out a memo
referencing these guys kind of like what
I sent out to the sponsors but saying
okay this is this and this who has it
this who has it and a little couple of
comments whatever like out here okay
yeah no I'm GL to see what you said just
so I know I'm being consistent or
covering the right yeah I'll have it out
probably Wednesday Thursday thank you
that way and I'll copy you
guys W I'm looking at the calendar right
now what what is the how does the 30th
sit with you
guys 10:30 do we need any special guests
to come other than do not come in
costume
right
yeah does that work for for you too as
well the 30th got to get home for trick
or
Retreat because we're going to have to
invite you to come in
costom what one or both of us will be
here but we can cover for each
other this one okay with you Jim the
30th good yeah
good
and when is that
the the 17th is the last day to okay so
I think the 13th would be good idea
because we could review what's what's
going to be addressed in that retained
sure session do we do we need to invite
anybody from the committee or you think
you can cover that uh rep wall and I are
on the committee so I think we should be
good youy
covered well let's let's put anyway why
don't we put that on the agenda for the
for the uh for the 30th that we'll
discuss we will discuss the uh the
upcoming retain Bill what's going what's
going to be in it any any last minute
ads or subtracts from that represent
dlan excuse me when Jen just mentioned
which is something we need to consider
as your this retained bill is going to
be amended it is going to change it and
with the speaker's um designation it
would be a non- derain Amendment so you
would have to have a public hearing on a
non- derain Amendment no we or would the
let's let
add so so so are you prepared to do that
or is this enough time to get that uh
notice
out well we have enough time to get it
out um if we're
GNA it would have to be a public hearing
and then an exec session after the 13
so either the 14th 15th or 16th of
November okay yeah yeah you can have the
N just before you accept it anyway we'll
need we'll need the amendment number
because put the proper notification in
the calendar we need the amendment
number so it'll have to be drafted ahead
of time so that means we would have to
get this solidified on the
30th October 30 still gives us uh gives
us two
weeks it still gives us the two weeks to
get the final like I
did that that sound good yeah you have
two weeks to to touch face your to folks
on your stuff I get get yes or
no yes let's be clear Vanessa what what
are we need on the 30th to give input to
the
committee theist the the list of
commissions that we're going to repeal
through S
sp84 and that's something we we could
formulate here and the list right but we
need to we need to give them something
yeah you not just you'll give it to rep
wall and I and then we'll create the
amendment for S sp84 we'll have a public
hearing and then an exec
session before the 17th everybody good
with
that we we know what I think it's
important for us just to know what the
mechanics are so that we we don't fudge
this uh let's invite representative uh
excuse me uh Dave
alus from
OS right because they they oh you're
gonna you're GNA do the OS going to do
the
amendment OS will do the amendment but
Jen for is here who's the researcher for
legislative Administration so she'll be
working we'll we'll work with repres she
and it's like we do with any um standing
committee should we have at next meeting
the 30th just give the heads up
I I still couldn't
hearon have him here at the 30th meeting
we could but this is just like any else
that we would do you normally wouldn't
we can but he doesn't usually come in to
that's just a question in your in your I
don't think it would be NE necessary to
Dave here I don't think Dave would need
to be here I know he's they're busy so
and in our meeting notices for for the
30th that we we'll publish will cover us
for you know being able to talk about we
don't need to have a public hearing no
no it's because legislative
Administration has possession of s sp84
which is going to be the
vehicle
okaye representative shean I sent you an
email with more details on the last
commission you just agreed to take and
leader Wilhelm if I can speak to you
afterwards for the regarding the one
that you took
just you know I offered to take it cuz I
thought there wasn't going to be any
work involved and now it seems like
there might be more work involved no no
it it's super easy I want to tell you
how easy it okay appreciate it thanks
deorah right exactly
yeah anybody else have any thoughts or
comments or worries yeah um
representative Dolan one of the items
that I just want to mention that we gave
a copy to the lsrs establishing a
committee or commission this is what's
coming up for
2024 and what we're doing in house
Services as we are looking each one up
we did leave notes right now where
there's a duplication so if there's a
similar commission that in existence or
how many times the same item may have
come up we're going to be putting in the
um farri column that's why we're calling
it a draft right now so um you you can
just look at this and see what we have
to date and we will have more for you by
the next um meeting like for instance
since um we have establishing an
independent redistri commission I
believe that legislation's come up four
or five times in the last several years
but just so you have a history of it as
we're moving forward because these are
all the
proposed committees or commissions for
2024 and um there's total of 30 15 and
15 and then we just start adding the
Senate collection so as you change
things over here they're still growing
over here well let me ask uh ask you
guys you both of you uh about our
process now these are all going to go to
the speaker and um the clerk I guess to
put their heads together to decide
whether or not we're actually going to
have a committee or
commission these are assigned to the
standing committees and it's Su standing
committee that makes that decision just
like a regular bill but I mean it it
could be that the speaker and the clerk
together could say this doesn't warrant
a committee or commission or it should
be combined you know numbers three and
four and seven ought to be all combined
into one is that do they make that
decision at at at their level no so
these will work just like any other bill
that comes forward the speaker and clerk
work together to assign them to the
appropriate policy committee policy
committee works with it but the the
speaker and clerk don't change any bills
that come to them
I got crap I stand up I notic one of our
members is putting in two
commissions well I was going to say you
know there are several that if you want
to try and dissuade a member you know
from signing off on on a study committee
or commission feel free except for those
two except for no I I just I just had to
say that come on you know that I'm
looking forward to a robust debate on
the floor
that in our second second year of the
term those will be assigned to you to to
kill well if you if you establish the
study committee uh this next year it's
going to go out of business in December
of next year anyway that's going to be a
quickie committee yeah that's right
which is great because you're going to
probably be heading it great you you
have your own destiny that's right no
but that's good that's good I knew what
I was getting myself into despite not
having the trifold wa is there is
there an and Deb is there is there
anything with these future committees
and commissions that we can do to help
facilitate
or to work with you on
these well um I don't think it's it's
whatever the member decide to put in for
an LSR for uh next year so I don't
know how you would want to proceed
that's why we're giving you that
background information and you you
can decide I I don't know because this
is all unchartered um territory we've
never put this together like this um in
anticipation what's coming up for a
committee
okay and I'm glad nothing's coming to
Commerce all right I think uh unless
anybody else has any comments I think
I'm doing we're good uh our next meeting
will be the 30th at one o'clock yep
right come prepare to discuss the retain
bills right thank you thank you all for
providing inputs on on the trifold it
was important that uh we get this
information to Ann and Deb I think I
think we had some constructive
feedback Food For Thought I gu put it
that
way
um and uh guess it's else anybody else
says anything we'll uh we'll cut it
right here and uh say thank you very
much and we'll be
adjourned very constructive meeting
today very
constructive